[Applause]
in the champions league it doesn't get
much better than being a fan of real
madrid by saturday night these
supporters could be celebrating title
number 14 twice as many as any other
club
i think we can beat liverpool we are not
satisfied with 13 champions leagues
liverpool's contingent are praying for a
mere seventh trophy and revenge for
defeat to madrid in the 2018 final
i think this is our year madrid won
seven of the last seven but the last
time they lost was
in paris i went to paris in 1981 when we
lost to liverpool
one nil i remember that day
history matters but it's the present
that has people tipping this final to be
a classic
these teams aren't just the best on the
european stage this season they're also
the most exciting liverpool have a
beautiful chemistry in attack while
madrid have mounted some of the most
dramatic comebacks this competition has
ever seen
french striker karen benzema is the
player who has made the difference to
madrid's fortunes scoring 10 goals in
the knockout stages
i'm treating the final naturally getting
into the final is a big success for us
we know how demanding this club is and
all about the club's history we think we
have had a very good season and reaching
the final has been very important for us
now we are very close to achieving
something huge this season and we will
give our all to achieve it
liverpool have more than one special
striker as they aim to stop rael's run
of seven wins in a row in the european
final
of course it's real madrid and of course
people bring it up but
we just focus on trying to win this game
we want to win the trophy we
you know when you get to the final
you're so close but it's the hardest
hurdle to get over and you know
hopefully we can hopefully we can be the
ones celebrating with many more fans
traveling than the seats available
tickets are being exchanged on the black
market for up to five thousand dollars
and counting
that's several times the monthly
earnings of those who live next to the
stad de france in san deni one of the
poorest areas in the country
on this bridge this is the separation
between the normal southern i should say
with such poor neighborhoods such as
this one from raison and on the other
side the state defense where there is
there are many major international
events such as the final of the ufo
champions league for example one thing
can be to make tickets more affordable
for people of suddenly because we are
the locals here we welcome the world but
we can't go inside the state de france
not staying locally could make getting
to the stadium difficult
rail workers are planning a strike to
coincide with saturday's final
on the pitch derailing madrid's french
striker could be the only way to end 41
years of real dominance
paul reese al jazeera paris